il conduit les caravanes de la main pour
vivre et la Clio traverse deux fois par
an le plus grand désert de sel du monde
il parcourt l’alty plane jusqu'au
Basse-Terre là-bas il échange des blocs
de sel contre des vivres
[Musique]
avant le départ de la caravane de
printemps il descend ses meilleurs bêtes
des hauts pâturages pour former sa
troupe une vingtaine pas plus
[Musique]
du village il a arrêté les longues
traversées il y a deux ans parce qu'il
ne pouvait plus marcher
il Ariane traîne une grande blessure
son fils Roberto depuis sa naissance
roberto est dans son monde le monde du
silence au village on dit qu'il est un
enfant des dieux
[Musique]
si Héra Clio avait un fils il lui
montrerait comment choisir les mâles les
plus vigoureux comment ajuster les
sangles avec force sans les blesser il
l'emmènerait sur les pistes des vallées
fertiles lui apprendrait à regarder le
ciel et à parler aux étoiles
Roberto ne s'est rien de tout ça
Roberto n'a qu'un seul ami son lama
blanc
dans ces montagnes
il n'y a pas de route pas de facteur
quand est la Clio s'en va tous les gens
du village lui confient un cadeau ou un
message pour un parent lointain le
liamero entend tous les secrets il est
le confident les mystère discret il
cultive toutes les histoires d'amour de
l'altiplane
[Musique]
pour cette femme une lettre à son mari
est liasse partie travailler dans les
mines de sel et à la Clio sait choisir
les mots ceux qui réconfortent maman
pour elle un cadeau pour sa fille en
couche et la Clio lui portera son
village est sur son chemin
[Musique]
et là Clio se déplace jusqu'au maisons
les plus isolées pour faire sa collecte
la fileuse aimerait que la Clio lui
rapporte des fruits contre les chars
qu'elle a tissé
[Musique]
où les volcans s'entretuent on ne part
jamais pour une heure un jour ou un mois
sans faire une offrande à la Pachamama
la mère de la terre des montagnes
le vieux liamero a pris sa décision
il va demander à era Clio de prendre son
fils mais pour ça le petit Roberto doit
accepter de se séparer de son lama blanc
[Musique]
s'échappent du village solitaire des
moquette Joa la langue des Incas des
mots simples ceux d'un père inquiet des
mots qui disent demain tu partiras avec
la Clio
Roberto entendu ces mots
dans les caravanes il y a toujours un
chef parmi les lamas c'est le plus
courageux le plus robuste mais aussi le
plus proche du liamelo pendant le voyage
les autres la mains le suivent et lui il
suit les ordres du liamel
[Musique]
le voyage est dur et puis ce gamin il
est si différent
il y a des choses qu'on ne peut pas
refuser
[Musique]
et la Clio est le petit Roberto
reviendront au village dans 3 mois
[Musique]
les lamas supportent les conditions
extrêmes des caravanes il marche des
heures sans boire sans brouter
pour Héraklion le lama est une mule et
un mouton en un seul animal la patamama
là aussi doté de coussins sous ses
pattes pour le rendre aussi silencieux
que le puma
[Musique]
les jours passent Roberto marche il ne
se plaint pas il ne sourit pas
[Musique]
et la Clio se sent seul avec ses lamas
eux il les connaît bien mais ce petit
être fragile replié dans son Pancho de
laine lui échappe
[Musique]
à chaque fois que le troupeau s'arrête
Roberto se blottit parmi eux c'est là
seulement qu'il semble vivre
les hommes et les lamas vivent ensemble
depuis des millénaires
il y a 5 siècles les Incas ont envoyé
des centaines de caravanes à travers les
Andes pour bâtir et ravitailler leur
immense empire
aujourd'hui
Héraklion emprunte toujours les mêmes
routes
[Musique]
femme va bientôt mettre un enfant au
monde la poupée représente un enfant
mâle elle accomplira les vœux de la
future mère
Roberto n'a pas eu de mer il n'a jamais
approché une femme enceinte
avant de traverser le désert de sel il
faut toujours passer chez Carlos
Carlos fabrique des chaussures et des
lunettes pour les lamas il dit que le
salar rend fou que le soleil se marie au
sel pour brûler les yeux et les pieds de
ceux qui le pénètre et ratio sait tout
ça mais à chaque fois il fait semblant
de l'écouter pour la première fois
on ne plaisante pas avec le salar
les Incas ont construit des cités
entières pour étudier les astres comme
tous les gens de son peuple et la Clio a
hérité d'une partie de leur savoir
il devine le destin du Yémen là-haut
tous les éléments de la vie se dessine
il voit le lama et son ennemi le puma
mais aussi les maisons rondes la
quenouille de la fileuse et les tombes
des ancêtres
loin de là le vieux Hilarion regrette de
ne pas être avec son fils pour lui
parler du Grand Désert Blanc des nuits
où le puma tourne autour du troupeau de
la Pajama qui ne l'a jamais abandonné
[Musique]
et le passage obligé des caravanes qui
vont vers le sud
300 km de désert blanc
hérissé de petites îles de lave brune
et la Clio avait l'âge de Roberto quand
il a traversé pour la première fois
[Musique]
héraklio achète ses pains de sel dans la
seule mine du salar il est sûr de
trouver Elias par ici
Élias n'a pas eu de nouvelles de sa
femme depuis 6 mois
[Applaudissements]
et la Clio ramènera un peu d'argent au
village
[Applaudissements]
le sel est chargé sur les rives
volcaniques du salar deux blocs par la
main 24 kilos par bet pas plus
répète à Roberto les précautions à
prendre avant la grande traversée il le
prévient contre les dangers ils seront
seuls il faudrait être fort marcher
marcher et ne pensez à rien d'autre
le puma affamé s'égare parfois dans le
désert de sel la nuit il peut tuer un
lama d'un coup de patte les gorgées le
traînaient jusqu'à la rive
et la Clio comme tous les liameros c'est
qu'il ne doit pas intervenir le puma est
sacré
[Musique]
les rayons du soleil brûlent les yeux la
croûte de sel ronge les chair
ici la vie n'a pas sa place
le pelage de lamas absorbe les
radiations du soleil et du sel
les liamels s'en servent pour protéger
les yeux de leur bête et jamais un homme
ne traverse le salar sans un bonnet en
laine de la main
[Musique]
dans le grand salaire on marche la nuit
et on se cache le jour
[Applaudissements]
et la Clio a lu un événement dans les
astres la rencontre de la Lune et du
soleil dans le monde inca cette
rencontre est un mauvais présage
[Musique]
la légende dit que le puma affamé essaye
de dévorer le soleil pour répandre
l'obscurité et installer le chaos sur la
terre
[Musique]
seul la pâte à Mama peut rétablir
l'ordre des choses quelques feuilles de
cocaïne un peu d'alcool pour apaiser sa
colère
[Musique]
Roberto s'est endormi les lamas se sont
enfuis
[Musique]
dans le salar et sans les mères les
lamas se dirigent toujours vers l'île la
plus proche là où ils savent trouver de
la nourriture
et dans ce désert l'île la plus proche
même si elle semble apporter de main
peut-être à plusieurs jours de marche
[Musique]
pour la première fois
Roberto mène la marche il veut retrouver
ses lamas
[Musique]
cette blessure n'est pas méchante le
puma emporté une bête mais le reste du
troupeau se porte bien
dans une semaine
ils arriveront au bout du voyage
dans la vallée des fleurs on parle
encore du Soleil Noir roberto est reçu
comme un héros les liameros et leur sel
sont attendus ici depuis des mois
[Musique]
sur le chemin du retour et la Clio a
confié au petit Roberto la conduite de
la caravane il aura fallu un mois pour
rentrer au pays
[Musique]
en chemin ils sont repassés chez la
femme enceinte elle a eu un petit garçon
elle l'a appelé Roberto
[Musique]
avec son argent la femme d'Elias le
salinero achètera quelques lamas pour la
laine
use rêvait de ses pommes avec elle tout
le village va en profiter
le voyage est terminé le petit roberto
est devenu liamero
conduire une caravane
dans le cœur du vieux Hilarion l'espoir
est revenu le village a trouvé un
nouveau liamel bien sûr
Roberto ne parle pas avec les hommes
mais pour tous ceux qui comptent
dorénavant sur lui il reste toujours
l'enfant des dieux
[Musique]